there are some figures in history whose
brilliant simply can't be ignored
figures who have shaped or influenced
intellectual climate to Major degrees or
who are so original and profound that
just reading their Works leaves you in
other awe regardless of your own
philosophical positions we've talked
about some of those characters already
on this channel and now we're back at it
again if you've been following this
channel then you should know by now that
the Islamic world has produced some of
the most ingenious thinkers in history
but even so among that group there are
some who stand out even more as kind of
watershed moments in Islamic philosophy
one such figure was IBN Cena or avisena
whose impact on this tradition is so
significant that all of Islamic
philosophy is often divided into a
pre-iben Cena versus post ibncena period
it's hard to match the stature and
importance of this man but if anyone
should be a contender at least in the
Easter certain parts of the Islamic
world it's probably the 17th century
philosopher Mulla sadra in Persia and
Central Asia no other figure has had an
impact comparable to this man in the
last few centuries his transcendental
philosophy is one that synthesizes some
of the most major intellectual
traditions in Islamic history the
peripatetic philosophy or Aristotelian
philosophy of IBN Cena the
illuminationist school of surabadi and
the mystical Sufi teachings of IBN Arabi
all of them into a magnificent Grand
system that still to this day is at the
core of some of the most prestigious
centers of learning in Iran so strap
yourselves in as we dive into the life
and thought of Mulla sadra
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sadradeen Muhammad ashirazi better known
as Mulla sadra was born in 1572 and as
his nespa suggests in the city of Shiraz
in modern Iran
he would spend basically all of his life
in Iran during the height of the safavid
Empire one of the three great modern
Islamic Empires sandwiched between the
Ottomans and the mughals as he grew up
and after receiving all the standard
education so learning the Quran Hadith
Islamic jurisprudence Etc he traveled to
Isfahan the imperial capital to deepen
his studies there under some other great
Scholars of his age it is here that he
studied under media damad who was
probably mainly responsible for teaching
him things like the illuminationist
philosophy of Surah vardi and the
peripatetic School of IBN Cena
his second major teacher in hisfahan was
better known as Sheikh Baha'i one of the
greatest Scholars of the safavid era who
was involved with everything from
astronomy to mathematics and mysticism
it is likely that much of mullah sada's
education in Sufism or erfan mysticism
as it is often on came from in
particular these mystical teachings
influenced as they were by the
philosophy of IBN Arabi would become one
of the major features of the sadrian
system the fact that mullah sadra
himself eventually became such a
renowned philosopher makes this
environment one that has become famous
for its intellectual flourishing
Scholars today often refer to this as
the so-called School of Isfahan as his
strong Resurgence of philosophical
activity in safavid Iran at this point
and no one would come to represent this
school and its syncretizing of different
intellectual Traditions more than
molassadra himself but a lot of his
renowned and influence would come only
after his death because indeed he did
run into some opposition once he had
finished his studies in Isfahan
mulasadra moved back to Shiraz but found
the intellectual environment there to be
rather hostile he's said to have been
harassed by a strict jurists and had
little room to develop or teach his own
philosophical ideas what was going on
here
Scholars argue that this was connected
to the spread of a movement in 12
varshiism called the achbaris so she is
jurisprudence or law had up until then
been primarily based on reason and the
reasoned interpretations of the jurist
called HD had
this mainstream group of shi Ilah came
to be known as the usulis but around
this time the achbaris started to become
more popular they were a group that were
a lot more strict in their understanding
of the law they favored a heavily
scriptural approach where only the Quran
and Hadith were to be used and wanted to
do away with the tradition of rational
interpretation in the dominant usuri
school and this meant that they were
strict in other areas as well including
the fact that they were very hostile
towards philosophy speculative Theology
and even more hostile to any Sufism or
edifan than the already skeptical of
sulis were it is likely representatives
of this akbari movement that mullah
sadra encountered in Shiraz and this
hostile environment forced him to
relocate to a small village outside of
Kum where he spent a number of years in
contemplation this period of seclusion
was very fruitful though as it is here
that he writes and lays the groundwork
for some of his most celebrated Works he
eventually returned to Shiraz in the
year 1613 and would kind of settle there
for the rest of his life although he
would lead a life that involved a lot of
traveling he visited different cities in
the region frequently went on several
pilgrimages to Mecca while riding his
great philosophical masterpieces he even
returned to teaching officially in
Shiraz in the year 1630 and in all of
this he somehow managed to raise a
family and gradually became a very
respected intellectual Authority
molassadra passed away in 1635 or 1636
probably in bastra while on his way back
from his seventh pilgrimage to Mecca but
he left behind a vast Legacy of both
students and writings that are still
studied in the highest seats of learning
in Iran to this day and it is to his
philosophical ideas that we now turn a
system that he himself as well as his
followers referred to as hecamat al-muta
Aliyah the Transcendent philosophy or
the Transcendent wisdom and we get
access to this wisdom primarily through
his writings even though he lived in
Persia and spoke Persian as an everyday
language he wrote basically all of his
Works in Arabic which was the lingua
Franca across the Islamic world for
religious and philosophical texts he
wrote a lot and we can't go through the
full list obviously but there are a few
writings that stand out as his most
influential and popular
first of all he wrote several
commentaries on quranic chapters or
verses books of Hadith as well as
commentaries on philosophical works such
as the ashifa by Eben Cena and the heck
metal
which we have covered in a previous
episode as for his own original Works he
wrote several treatises that explicated
his unique metaphysical ideas
his magnum opus the largest most
well-known and arguably the most
impressive of his entire output is the
Monumental work called
Transcendent philosophy in four
intellectual Journeys often referred to
in English simply as before Journeys or
in the shortened Arabic this is a
massive compendium in several volumes
that covers his entire thought and a lot
of his other writings are often seen
simply as summaries of certain aspects
of the asfar among these shorter works
we find treatises like the kitabel
mashair the book of metaphysical
penetrations the heck metal arshia the
wisdom of the throne and a book on Sufi
principles called Exile artifin elixir
of the gnostics all of which have been
translated into English
the asphalt or four Journeys however
sadly remains untranslated for the most
part so then what do we find in these
Works what is the transcendental
philosophy of mulasadra well as you can
imagine there's a lot of different
aspects and complexities it's a vast
system of philosophy that you know
obviously we can't cover all of it in a
single episode but there are a few
Central aspects of his thought often
pointed out by Scholars as the most
Central or important aspects of this
philosophy they include perhaps most
importantly the concept of the Primacy
and Oneness of a being as well as the
gradation of being and then also various
ideas that stem or result from that
basic principle such as the idea of
substantial motion and the something
known as the unity of the knower and the
known now all of this is just terms that
sound confu using to many of you but
they will become more clear as we go
forward now to fully grasp molassadra
it's very helpful to have an idea of the
philosophical ground that he stands on
because indeed malasada's philosophy is
a syncretic one at its core it brings
together some of the most important and
influential traditions of philosophy and
mysticism and just you know Islamic
thoughts in history I've often said that
I couldn't make an episode on mulasadra
before I made one on ibncena one on Eben
Arabi and one on Surah vardi because
these are essentially the three figures
and the three philosophical or
intellectual Traditions that he is
building his entire system on the
peripatetic Aristotelian philosophy of
IBN Cena or avisana is harmonized with
the illuminationism of Surah vardi which
proposes that reality is made up of
light and that light is gradational
everything is lights only different
grades or intensity of light with the
most luminous light of lights or neural
Anwar being identified with God himself
and thirdly the mystical Sufi thought of
IBN Arabi which has become known as or
the unity of being and which proposes
that only God truly exists and is
identical to being or existence itself
making reality a radical Oneness also
has his central place in molassadra's
thought so if you want to have an even
better grasp of what we're talking about
today I suggest you go back and consult
my earlier episodes on these figures and
their philosophy first in any case at
the very heart of molassadra's
transcendental philosophy is the concept
of being or in Arabic
indeed we mentioned the Primacy of being
a salad as one of the core features of
his thoughts
is a complex term it is usually used to
mean being or existence but can also
literally mean finding as in to find
something and to be aware of it is a
term that has been used across the
history of Islamic philosophy but has
been interpreted in slightly different
ways
very importantly it was IBN Cena that
conceptually divided things into being
on the one hand and essence or quiddity
on the other
we already know what wajood is it is
being or existence in itself but Essence
or quiddity might be more difficult for
those who haven't studied philosophy and
here the Arabic term might actually help
a bit the term used in Arabic is mahiya
or literally whatness what a certain
thing is think of it like this we can
ask two questions about any given object
such as a horse for example we can ask
what is it and we can ask is it
when we ask what is it we are asking a
question of essence or whatness the
answer in this case horse is the essence
or liquidity or the wetness of that
object it is a horse its Essence is a
kind of hoarseness right but when I ask
is it I am asking a question of being
the answer to the question is either yes
or no either it has existence or it
doesn't
so this is the distinction between
wujood and Mahia between being and
whatness or Essence wajood is the pure
concept of being itself whereas Mahia or
Essence is the whatness of a thing
that's all good and well but Islamic
thinkers in history have vastly
disagreed on the relationship between
these IBN Cena himself seemed to think
that the distinction between them is
only mental
followers in the illumination School
however famously held to the idea of the
Primacy of quiddity in the hikmatology
he argues that it is the essence of
things that truly exist and that
existence is only an arbitrary category
that we mentally impose upon them but
which does not really exist in reality
paradoxically he essentially says that
existence doesn't exist
it's quite a complex argument and you
can watch my episode on surabandi for
some more context to this but the idea
had become quite popular by the time of
molassadra it seems to have been the
idea that his teacher meeted Ahmad held
and that Sadler himself ascribed to
earlier in his life
but at some point he changed his
position completely perhaps inspired by
the teachings of IBN Arabi mullah
instead argues that it is being or
existence that is the only reality and
that Essences orquidities are only
mental constructs that we impose upon
the reality of being
the only thing that is out there so to
say the only thing that is is being
itself
and it gives many arguments for why
so imagine for example an apple you can
think about an apple in other words the
essence of an apple can exist in your
mind but if you're hungry that mental
image isn't going to help you quench
that hunger only if there is an apple
that exists out there an Apple that has
existence can it be effective quote that
these things won't existent in reality
have all these effects must then be down
to something else than their Essence
Essences can have real examples for all
that they mean only if being is attached
to them reality is being being is all
there is in essence then this is a
monistic outlook on things because
indeed being is one
there aren't a bunch of different
examples of being there's only one being
one existence which is all of reality
remember what we said about the thought
of IBN Arabi and the unity of being he
identified being or would as God and
said that God is all there is
adopt a lot of IBN arabi's thinking
about
here too God is God is being existence
itself
God doesn't have existence God isn't a
being he is being or existence itself
just based on this fact and considering
the central Islamic teaching of
monotheism that God is one this
necessarily leads to conclusion that
being or existence is one in other words
all of reality is simply the one being
this is the idea of the Primacy of being
as well as the unity of that being which
set mulasada apart from his teachers and
figures like surravardi he took the idea
that it was the Essences that truly
exist and turn it around completely
instead arguing for the very opposite
but how does this account for
multiplicity clearly there are different
things in the world at least as we
experience it we don't experience
reality as a single Oneness so what's
going on here well as we saw malasadra
argued that the Essences or wetnesses of
things the things that make things
distinct from each other are only mental
constructs that we impose upon the
Oneness of being but still there
certainly seems to be a difference
between me and the dinosaur or a leaf
and the Sun Well I said that is not a
radical monist in that way he's not
saying that there is no reality to a
multiplicity that multiplicity is simply
an illusion as many other perhaps
Mystics in history have he does leave
room for a kind of Multiplicity within
this Unity of and it is
applies the fascinating thought of Surah
vardadi if you remember sort of already
conceived of the world as made up of
Lights in different grades or
intensities
the difference between things or
quidities can be explained by the fact
that there are different grades of light
and thus become different things
molassadra sees in this a perfect
solution to his problem with the only
difference that he applies to the
concept of or being in other words
molassador argues that being itself can
be more or less intense
there is a gradation of being which goes
from the most pure and intense the
absolute being of God to the less
intense such as matter and the physical
world
so everything in the universe is simply
a mode of wizard or being it is all won
by the fact that it is all Buju but that
wujood has different grades of intensity
which leads to the multiplicity of
things
quote being is a reality which in its
Unity runs through all things in
different degrees and gradations
just like an Essence such as whiteness
can have different levels of intensity a
snowflake can be more white than the
color of your sort of creamy white wall
he instead argues that it is being
itself that has these grades of
intensity
this leads to claim that different
things in the world can exist more than
others I can exist more than you and the
sun can exist more than a worm
this is a little jarring to the modern
mind which usually conceives of reality
in very different ways but it is key to
molassadra
in his own words quote the modalities of
existence have different degrees some
are intellective some are related to the
soul and some are dark without any
perception
to him language is based on a
misunderstanding and thus the way we use
language to explain reality leads to
further confusion to say that the horse
exists is absurd because everything is
being including the horse which means
that we're essentially saying that the
horse exists before it exists you know
if you look grammatically at that line
you say horse exists and according to
certain grammar rules the subject of the
predicate is supposed to exist before
the predicate so we're saying that the
horse exists before it exists where at
the very least we're simply saying that
being exists
or that being is which is not saying
anything at all in the words of Saya
hemisami quote according to molassadra
the problem is simply a misunderstanding
since Essences are nothing but the
reflections of beings in the mind that
is the limitations of the one reality in
reality there are only beings and
therefore existential statements should
be read in Reverse for example man
exists should be read as this mode of
being is man
being is all there is and everything is
the one being but that being becomes
delimited into various things through
its gradation of intensity according to
Ibrahim Kalin quote there is only one
single reality in existence but it
travels through the entire circle of
existence leaving a different Mark at
every level existence remains a single
immutable reality at the roots of all
things but it also displays an infinite
number of Shades colors modes and
modalities
however this is not some kind of crude
pantheism is also very adamant to remain
a kind of difference or distinction
between God and created things the
absolute independent being is of course
very different from dependent and
relational things all things quote
unquote other than God are referred to
as being in another
just like a horse can have a collar
which is dependent on the horse being
there even though the color can be
thought of in the mind as a thing of its
own and even though out there in reality
they are unified so there is a
distinction between Creator and created
molassador here very cleverly Compares
it to a light source and its streams of
light there is a certain difference
between the sun itself and the Rays that
emit from it even though they are also
kind of the same thing at the same time
quote apart from the one Transcendent
truth every being is only a ray of the
light of his very being he is the truth
and the rest are his manifestations he
is the light and the rest are the
streaks of that light
in a very clever move molassador refers
to God as quote that simple reality
which is all things but none of those
things in particular the thing that is
all things cannot be any of them in
particular in fact he uses arguments
similar to that of the Christian Mystic
Meister Eckhart where the indistinctness
of being is the very thing that makes
being the most distinct because being is
all things that is what makes it
different from everything because it is
the only thing that can be everything
it is a complex and masterful
metaphysics that has significant
implications many of you may note that
these ideas are very similar to those of
the famous Mystic event Arabi and again
this is true for the obvious reason that
IBN Arabi was one of the main influences
on his thinking possibly the most
important influence but there are also
significant differences between them
perhaps Chief among them mulasadra was a
philosopher and IBN Arabi wasn't
what do I mean by this well even Arabi
is usually described as a Mystic and he
can't really be counted as a philosopher
in the more narrow sense of that word
if an Arabi doesn't construct thought
out Arguments for his ideas or attempt
to build any kind of system
instead he has mystical insights and
visions and simply retells them in often
disjointed ways as well as simply
commenting on and interpreting scripture
on the other hand was a trained
philosopher and it takes many of the
core features that we can find in the
mystical writings of the bin alabi and
his successors and kind of places them
within a philosophical framework using
arguments and actually building a
breathtaking system from it it's amazing
stuff but aside from this molassadra
still places a major importance on
mystical insights he uses rational
arguments sure but he also is very
careful to point out that to truly
experience these things one cannot reach
this knowledge through through the
intellect or through at least through
rational argumentation or thinking but
rather through mystical unveiling and a
direct experience of these truths so in
other words the Sufi influence is very
strong here but it's worthwhile here to
explore the relationship between Mula
sadra and his regeneral environments and
Sufism at this time because it is quite
complicated molassadra was a shi Muslim
living in safavid Persia Sufism or
tasawof on the other hand has mostly
been a Sunni affair with some exceptions
and indeed during the safavid era Sufism
was being increasingly looked down upon
by the 12 Rishi scholars in this region
to them it represented Innovation that
had led the sunnis astray
Sufism had become something dirty
however a distinction was drawn between
this Sufism which had come to refer to
the different practices associated with
the tradition like things like grave
visiting Victor sessions Sama musical
riots Etc on the one hand and the more
speculative esoteric metaphysical
teachings associated with certain
Mystics like IBN Arabi on the other this
theoretical side of Sufism started being
referred to as erfan and this was
accepted to a much larger degree so when
figures like molassador are talking
about things which many would associate
with Sufism they would never say that
this is Sufism that they are involved
with rather it would be erfan the
mystical knowledge of hidden realities
or simply hikmah wisdom words that they
would use rather than Sufism indeed Mala
himself is very critical of
quote-unquote Sufism and its practices
in his writings even though he clearly
takes influence from its theoretical
teachings particularly in his ideas
about or being which as we have seen lie
at the very core of his system
it is from this principle of the Primacy
Oneness and gradation of being that all
other aspects of his philosophy stem and
allows him to solve quote unquote some
long-standing problems in Islamic
philosophy and present some truly
innovative ideas one such core often
quoted idea is that of the unity of the
knower and the known just like surabaldi
before him molassadra rejects the
peripatetic idea that knowledge of
things come about from a mental
abstraction of universals based on an
experience of a sensible object that I
see a horse and then my mind abstracts
Universal Concepts from the horse to
give me knowledge about what it is that
I'm seeing instead molassadra adopts to
ravari's idea of el malhoduri knowledge
through presence
we come to know things through their
direct presence to our awareness we know
the particular things that we experience
not just universals but but the
particular things as they are present to
us
building on this molassadra also
incorporates his principles of by also
stating that presence is the same as
being
in other words when we know a thing we
are united with that thing
the subject is united with the object as
it were in this way the human soul can
Ascend on the ladder of being from the
lower physical or sensible world through
the imaginal and the highest
intellectual world through gaining
knowledge being present and uniting with
knowledge which takes him higher on this
ladder to our spiritual goal it is a
complex epistemology that is deeply
connected to his metaphysics of being
and was quite unique at the time
similarly Scholars will often point to
the principle of substantial motion as
one of the most important features of
the sadrian system because it allows him
to present some really interesting
perspectives on eschatology and the soul
the idea of substantial emotion is kind
of exactly what it sounds like it
proposes that substance itself is
changing and evolving
so in the philosophical tradition
particularly Aristotelian philosophy the
consensus had been that things are made
up of substance and accidents things
have a substance that is fixed and
unchanging but this substance can have
accidents which vary and change
so for example both me and you are human
beings this is a kind of substance which
doesn't change but we have accidental
attributes which differ us I may be
taller than you or we have different
hair colors maybe you are a woman and
I'm a man or to steal an analogy apples
on a tree can have different sizes and
colors or be in different places while
all remaining the same substance Apple
you've been seen identified a couple of
accidents that could be in motion
quality quantity place and position
but while a theme can be in different
places varying in accidental features
there is a substance which remains
unmoving and unchanged so to say but
molassadra disagreed instead arguing
that both accidents and substance are in
constant motion they are constantly
changing and moving towards perfection
why is this well because everything is
simply being and different grades of
that being this means that being can
change while remaining the same
so substance being modes of being are
also changing
think of a tree it begins as a seed then
as a small Bush later it becomes a
full-blown tree and eventually that tree
will Blossom and result in things like
apples
Adra there aren't different instances of
substances here Apple being one
substance and tree being another because
all things are simply the unfolding of
being
the substance is moving towards its
Perfection the seed becomes the Apple in
a continuous flow it is only us that
mentally frees that flow at a particular
time to say that this is a tree or this
is an apple
but really it is a constant motion of
being moving towards increasing
perfection
everything in the world is constantly
changing and being renewed in its very
substance or being and this may not
sound like something revolutionary but
it really allows malasada to make some
significant contributions to a few of
the most hotly debated topics and
questions in Islamic Theology and
philosophy for example the question of
the eternity of the world this had been
very famously argued by figures like IBN
Cena and araklazali the philosophers
like IBN Cena and those of his of his
kind would often argue generally not all
of them but generally would argue that
the world was eternal because time is a
concept that only exists in the created
world so to say this means that there
couldn't be a time before the universe
began right so while God originates or
creates the world he does so outside of
time and so from our perspective
creation is an eternal thing right God
is ontologically proud prior to the
world but not temporally prior to the
world theologians such as al-hazali
strongly disagreed and basically saw
this as pure unbelief they believed that
the Quran very clearly states that God
created the world at a specific time
created the world from nothing
essentially and so they were very
adamant to hold to this particular
belief but mulasada takes a kind of
middle position he denies the idea of
the eternity of the world and affirms
that he believes in its temporal
origination but unlike the theologians
he does not believe that the world or
creation was originated at a specific
point in time in its entirety that all
of it just came about in one instance
partly for the same reason that time is
a product of creation and so there can't
be a time before there is bodies so it
can be a time before there is there are
things there's a there's a cosmos in
which time can can make sense and
because of the doctrine of substantial
motion that everything is constantly in
motion changing and being renewed he
asserts that creation is taking place at
every instant
just like even Arabi he states that
because everything is being renewed at
every moment this means that quote every
particle of the world is forever being
temporarily originated
rights of the world is temporarily
originated or created but that creation
is taking place at every single instant
technically it takes place outside of
time right because God is outside of
time but from our perspective at every
moment creation is being renewed there's
a new creation at every instant this is
an idea that we find in Arabi and
molassadra seems to adopt it to a large
degree similarly substantial motion
allows him to present solutions to the
problem of bodily resurrection and the
afterlife of the Soul as we've seen this
was another one of those very
contentious issues figures like IBN Cena
philosophers arguing that the idea of a
bodily Resurrection at the day of
judgment could not be proven and could
not be sort of believed in from a
rational point of view instead arguing
that that belief should be taken simply
on faith or that those verses should be
read in some way kind of metaphorically
and again theologians
accused IBN Cena for these reasons of
being an unbeliever and stated that
belief in an actual bodily Resurrection
is required belief for all Muslims
molassadra again comes with a kind of
conciliatory approach
according to the principle of
substantial motion the human soul can
travel or evolve from being strongly
connected with the body and the material
world to eventually become increasingly
refined and enter the imaginal and
lastly the intellectual worlds now after
death the soul is able to create a kind
of body in the imaginal world this is
not a physical body but rather an
imaginal body what does this mean well
according to thinkers like IBN Arabi
there is an imaginal world
that stands in between the material
world and the higher intellectual world
this world of imagination becomes very
important for many mystical ideas but we
don't have time to fully explore it here
in any case the state of the Soul upon
death that is how refined the person has
managed to make the soul through
following religious laws and pursuing
knowledge will determine what kind of
body that soul will get or creates in
the imaginal world a very greedy person
can take on the body of a pig whereas a
spiritually accomplished Soul can create
a subtle beautiful body higher in the
great of being and thus closer to God it
is these imaginary bodies that determine
the state of one's afterlife
a refined intellectual solar body will
be high in the chain higher in the
gradation of being and thus closer to
God and this is Paradise
but those of a dirty Soul who get a body
that instead experiences the Pains of
the fire or what is often termed hell so
as you can tell he again takes a kind of
middle position he allows for bodily
Resurrection but this is a body that
isn't physical but rather imaginal
there are many other aspects of
malasada's philosophy and theology that
could be explored but we would be here
all day needless to say his system
includes rational arguments for things
like prophecy and Revelation Divine
attributes and because he was a Shiite
the concept of Wallah and the authority
of the Shiite imams who represented the
very height and Pinnacle of sainthood to
him for all these reasons that we have
discussed molassadra is perhaps the
pre-eminent Islamic philosopher in Iran
today his legacy is massive and he is
often perhaps rightly referred to as the
most significant Islamic philosopher
after IBN Cena at least in the East
while he had students who carried
forward his transcendental wisdom his
popularity didn't pick up right away
the later years of the safavid Empire
saw an increasing distrust of anything
related to mysticism or philosophy on
part of the more strict akbari Scholars
and there was a lot of suppression of
such intellectual Endeavors it is really
in the kajal and palavi periods that
molassadra really starts becoming the
incredibly influential figure that he is
today over the course of the 18th to
20th centuries his work became Central
aspects of study in the major centers of
education and some of the most famous
and important she Scholars have been
deeply involved with his thought
figures like said Abu Hassan Rafi
al-kleswini Muhammad Hussein
and even perhaps surprisingly to some
Ayatollah Khomeini were all experts in
sadrastat and hugely influenced by him
we also have major thinkers such as said
Jose Nasser who founded the Imperial
Iranian Academy of philosophy dedicated
to studying the so-called perennial
wisdom in which sadhara played a major
role Nasser and his efforts have been
important for introducing molassadra and
other Islamic thinkers to a worldwide
audience together with colleagues and
students such as Andre carbon William
chiddick and James Morris just to
mention a few as we find ourselves in
the 21st century molassadra is
recognized worldwide as one of the most
spectacular thinkers in Islamic history
and is studied in many different parts
of the globe there was even a World
Congress of molassadra in 1999 in which
Scholars from all around the world
participated with a philosophical Legacy
as a rich deep and complex as that of
sadradeen Muhammad ashirazi we are still
trying to understand some of the nuances
of his amazing thought any understanding
of the Islamic intellectual world today
is not complete without some familiarity
with molassadra whose incredible
syncretic approach of bringing together
some of the most important strands of
Islamic thought in history from
mysticism to Greek inspired philosophy
into a grand amazing system has earned
him a place as one of the most
significant thinkers in history
I'll see you next time
[Music]